over here but it has to be two road
links apart oh okay let's see what i'm
saying
yeah so you can move that
there or there and you can put your
settlement over there or you know
yeah
there you go
you have enough money for all that um
you already paid for the road yes i put
those down first and i can't play this
yeah if you want
cool
you can play before your turn
so this is nick sapoglia very funny
comedian from
fresno california
oh [ __ ] okay
maybe we'll cut that part out
yeah don't you put it up in front of you
oh
you show everyone what you did
but yeah i mean uh you had a great set
at different places thank you thank you
what do you think about the awesome
comedy scene better than fresno right
yeah it's just it's just bigger and
there's more to do like so i'm enjoying
that um it's actual
comedy clubs and big shows to go to and
just watch and hang out and see stuff at
back home and it's just
an open mic like three days a week oh my
god and then like so you did it five
years there i did seven years there but
i was also like traveling to like the
sea because fresno was directly in the
middle of california so like san
my whole family's there that's where i
was born and raised and obviously you
didn't want to move well no i was just
living there before i started doing
comedy i decided to go back to school so
and then i got into comedy while i was
in college and then i just i was just
like i'm gonna still want to complete my
goal of like graduating college so i did
that and then yeah and then the family
business you know and it was good money
and it set me up pretty good i own a
house out there and you know like i mean
nice i don't have any debt or anything
you know that you wanted to do real
comedy i'm not just fresno comedy yeah
and i was tired of driving three hours
to la or san francisco or sacramento
just to do a spot and then drive back
because i had worked the next day if i
wanted to be like you like a gym shop
uh in san francisco and la and i've
performed out there in a bunch of places
like yeah little clubs and bars up in
san francisco some of the clubs down
southern california yeah some of the
clubs not saying it's a bad thing but
it's like not ideal and it's crazy that
you made it work in fresno yeah
just i've drive driven i've driven i've
driven a total of you know eight hours
for five to ten minutes to stand up and
in a 24 hour period like a bunch of
times
yeah and then having to come back and go
to work the next day at 8 am so it's
like worth more and you're like actually
trying and you don't want to fail so
you're used to high pressure
environments
um
i uh
i mean i've had plenty of bombs but i've
never really bombed it at like an actual
spot like a club or anything where it's
because it's just like too much was
riding on it with my anxiety's going
through the roof but i'd go out and
perform and do my thing and you know
it's fun i love a great style for that
too because it's like well-written jokes
thank you
so you just read off a teleprompter
what
did you have like more college kids or
was it like uh because fresno has a
college right fresno bulldogs yeah
that's where i went did you
did you get like would you find like
more college kids were active in the
comedy scene in fresno or was it like
more just like honestly like there's
like right there's like 10 15 comics
like that's it and they're all random
like there's uh probably
seven or eight young kids
no i mean like at the show like the
audience
oh no it would be random because like
and for us now like if like we'd have a
good show but there's no club there to
perform there's no like designated spot
in town where people can go and see
comedy
so it's like like out there people book
shows
and they like sell their tickets and
they hustle and they'll like pack out
rooms or restaurants or [ __ ] like that i
got you and um but
i've had some really good shows out
there too and
comics do come through you know you get
like get to do like feature spots for
them when they're in town at their shows
so it was fun what were you doing there
a farm so you wouldn't want to trade
no um my parents on a right yeah i don't
know glass shop i just stoned i have a
hay jars uh
hay or lumber i'm willing to trade one
of these for stone either you guys want
to trade wait excuse me what did you say
i need sam piper from alabama just
started comedy in austin all right
hey hey wait can you give me a brick or
yeah i'm pretty new i've been writing
comedy for like three or four years i'll
give you a hay for stone
no or kind of comedy no
uh different things uh sketches and just
jokes like i've been wanting to do
comedy for a while so i started acting
and like theater being just a goofy guy
so like i like i like i've always like
been comfortable uh on like yeah theater
no i don't dance
dude that's why i didn't do acting in
school is because you had to sing and
dance and i didn't want to do that i
just wanted to like act yeah i didn't do
musical theater i never i yeah and i
should have gone to a bigger school
like a year yeah that's cool we had it
we were
pretty private
all the good schools are like if you
want to get a good education where i was
from
you had to go to a private school wait
did you say that you did plays
yeah i started
i thought i just made that up no since i
was like five i was the gingerbread man
that was the first play i ever did never
walk back it was the town [ __ ]
yeah
favorite nickname for me
um [ __ ] did you trade me by the way
lumber or hay they like they like
the gingerbread man and i got something
parking lot no man no i didn't
experience any of that
so no one's gonna give me any stone i
don't have a brick i mean no that's what
i'm talking about we don't have a brain
here no there's a little game in katana
little christie has a city and a
settlement so she has three points
separate has three settlements
one two three so that's three points and
then i have two and sam is two and then
if your house is on the little vertex
and you pick up all the resources around
it
uh this city means she gets double of
these resources okay
and it's just a fun game
all right well no i can't do anything
i'm a pass there you go
eleven oh let's go
aviator nation was so dope last night
can anyone give me a break please no it
looked really funny for wood yeah the
crowd there is like super hip
yeah and by that i mean super fit yeah
and um yeah those jackets were super
rather expensive
dude their hats are filling up
cool spot uh but it's so expensive they
have a stage back there did you see this
i've seen the stage yeah it's that's
what i was saying earlier it seems like
i don't ever hear of events going on
there but it looks like they have the
perfect setup
yeah
yeah it was it do you know who it was
like cool that was the first event they
did it's the second comedy but they have
six uh music there oh yeah but it's like
a super uh california branded
i mean it's not california
but it's like surfer vibes and yeah
like
white people rich people hobbies like
middle class white people hobbies like
hang gliding yeah oh wow
it's just like super bougie and it's
like it's like not super rich but it's
like a ski lodge
it's kind of like a california vibe in a
way that's accurate to say uh yeah but
not like yeah
it is it's kind of like you gotta build
roads first roads first
you can't just
put us colorado in the middle of nowhere
where's huntington beach it's south of
l.a right southern lake that's where all
the conservatives are nice yeah i think
uh
it'll be a clean beach
we mean looking more polluted
yeah san diego's pre ever been
seen the beaches like they full of like
kelp and it's like bugs all over it you
know potato ortiz
has a gym there
you ever been to san diego huntington
beach yeah
it's been everywhere man
i've been everywhere man are you done
i'm done pass
did you care for san diego versus
huntington
sure
chrissy has four points
six
anyone want wheat
no thank
you give me a break
yeah
anyone have wood what did he do six six
or
[Music]
a sheep
once we
one
two
three
four
i'm pretty good for a rock
i don't have a rock i have wheat that's
all i have i only have a sweet
drilled on here and then i pass
12.
nice
now i get a shape
all right so i'm going to do a couple
things
i'm on the board
god
yeah that's the check that that good
palms all right
cause would you put our name in there
yeah
no rats mcgee
depression stick
i offered you a ride today i said do you
want to go to the airport i didn't need
to go to the airport today i need to go
to the airport
but i could afford to today
i was like let's go dude can't you go
hang out at the airport if you asked i
would have paid you
what are you
dude that's what i'm trying to tell you
is it was a casual i was just saying
casually like oh dude i don't know if i
can like this is crazy
oh my god why are you [ __ ] making me
do this ugh
and then if you're gonna do that show me
the example you're saying that i'm gonna
be like well let's [ __ ] you you're the
one that like lost your cool
in the mess yeah they did
because you're putting up what's i think
i think what it is is you're making all
these new friends that are like cool and
so you just like you're just like oh
like chrissy you're like here's all my
problems
i have a lot of difficulties in my life
and that's why i can't sacrifice any
difficulties
to help you i just couldn't do it that
day for sure i was like really out of it
out of it dude you know like what does
that mean i cried like the day before i
finally got the money i like asked the
one guy and he said no good
it's funny because yeah your life is
really depressing and [ __ ] and that's
why you can't give me a ride so like
what's the point if you're always gonna
be depressed maybe this is funny to you
but um
it's not funny to me because you've been
gone for like two weeks
at this point
i have to pee can i just do that
yeah you compete all right
just sit down
wait
is it about to be my turn it is your
turn 12.
before
damn that's a lot of stuff
four here
so you picked up two bricks oh and i get
one for each settlement yeah yeah it
says it's two it's two yeah i got two
okay okay yeah but you didn't pick up a
wood right okay
no oh you don't you're not supposed to
do it
i can't get out of here
could you please roll so i can pick up
resources
we'll pick it up for you
i don't trust you right now trust sam
will do it
10 10.
nice
does anybody have stone would like some
brick
yes
i need two stones
okay she gets to rock too she did uh she
goes
awesome
so what do you think about ukraine
russia's taking over i think that it's
funny that
like russia has basically declared their
war with ukraine and america and like
the u.n is just like sure their biggest
response to is like russia
you
if you do that we're gonna give you
the big sanctions
but that's like really their way of just
saying like i don't give a [ __ ]
you guys hey they're just doing what
china did to tibet right just taking it
over i mean i think it's just funny this
is different because they're american
other
countries are just like i'm not getting
that [ __ ] you guys got it
well i think after the cold war we
didn't treat russia very well now
they're aggressive
uh yeah that's there's two than that
six
two of those because i have a oh my god
anyone want weight
yeah i'll give you uh
wheat for
a lumber
do you want weight
um i need
i do need wheat
for what for rock brick
no
rock or
no sorry okay
turn
i picked up your resources for you
thank you
uh
we just wanted to i just wanted to sam
you have three
um
i would like to trade with you though
since i
assisted you
i know you have a lot of ore right now i
could use some are you gonna try to like
do some kind of weird trade just well i
have a sheet and i just need some more
i'll do one or if you want to be
generous to get rid of some cards
because you got somebody i'll take two
or even three what are you talking about
that's insane what about one sheep for
two more
okay what is this
you want to give me a sheep yeah yeah
for two i want to give you
you have a lot dude i only have one
right now that's not true you just got
four do you think anyone else is going
to come he's got two i don't know
i hope so because this uh thank you
all right kidding dude i thought that
sam lopez was coming i'm done she's in
houston right now oh
what is christy's turn
you don't think women are people
i mean who does
um eight
thank you
i like it god damn it
you guys are definitely winning
you know why this board is [ __ ] up is
because you're not supposed to have two
reds touching each other
um but you guys already placed all your
[ __ ] down and i was like [ __ ] it let's
see what happens
but if this happens the person that went
first has an advantage because now
there's higher spots and everything else
sucks yeah so yeah
now you winning she's winning
it's uh it's just a weird coincidence
well i didn't i didn't roll the highest
that makes sense i guess we got the
place first yeah i mean you got this
spot this spot's two eights and a five
yeah
that's that's who wants
what do you have that you want
i want a brick
oh i don't know
i'll give you a lumber for uh or
won something over here
all right so that's my turn you can take
it now
both the settlement
four five
maybe you should focus more on this than
uh
you know oh you're not actually winning
you're not doing that well ten we'll see
not you sam oh i'm not winning no
ten mm-hmm
god damn
christy's winning yeah for sure i'll
ruin it
did you pick
sure
nick's actually doing pretty good too
i'm gonna buy this developmental card
development card development
developmental is um
does anyone want to trade i have two
lumberjack level four one
four
what i'll give two why are you trading
right now it's not your turn isn't
anyone allowed to trade in the trading
nope that's not true yep it's a return
no i know but
yeah only like you can only trade with
the person who's just doing that 10.
must be
anyone want weight
no what about sheep
no i need to work
what about or
yeah i got lumber
two lumber
two lumber for one over yeah yeah i said
it i'll do it
okay
anyone want
sheep you have brick no
okay
now i just need
one more thing
six
six
if i get any more
uh
what's another talking point
[Music]
um six
is it my turn
yeah
so what was so
difficult about that thing you can't
give me
11.
um the bank froze my
bank account and that my gas light was
on so you're feeling a little sad
yeah the coinbase guy
straight up broke up with me
and the other two were like ghosting me
and he went out
i like how you go
he broke up with me but the other two
yeah the other two were like ghosting me
and then the one that the house that i
was staying at he said no to giving me
money so i was just like
sitting there just
freaking out
and then you're like hey could i have a
ride and i was like dude i don't know
all these guys are rejecting you and
there's your faithful old pal helens
yeah
he's always there for you but like maybe
you need to be maybe you need to be able
to like be a good friend even when
somebody can't do one if someone's being
a complete [ __ ]
dude i did like 13 favors for you in a
row and like i couldn't do one i'm sorry
i burdened you with so many favors no
but like oh because you're like oh my
god you can't force me to do things did
i say that yeah
well no no i remember saying the word
force but i didn't say it like badly
it was pretty bad
no you were bad like you were the one
that was like
you know
mad
like you were actually saying that i was
like annoyed that you were like giving
me stick
i said it just i called sam and he goes
no
i'm near the airport like it's going to
be fun yeah i set that up you didn't
help me at all yeah i know but you were
just complaining dude sam and you are
easy you easily just texted him probably
is it my turn
it's my turn i'm just waiting for her
yeah
but you easily probably texted him and
it was fine
but like you didn't have any like
empathy over the fact that like that you
were having no empathy over me i like
how she's being like not caring about me
i can understand that i have empathy
about how she doesn't have empathy for
me oh it's it's i drew an 11.
yeah he did
yeah
but like
there's oreos
oh common oreo yeah yeah
i'm trying to get rid of them
yeah
yeah well you know
but like when your life is falling apart
and stuff you don't need like more
people being like hey we were friends
let me not help another friend of mine
so that they can feel the pain i'm
feeling let me pay it forward dude i'm
sure you had a great trip like i'm sure
you were like having a good time
didn't you make out with a bunch of
people after your shows
and then you just
so then you were having a great trip
yeah so you could afford to be negative
to me
[Music]
yeah
i mean i had a really difficult week
so that was beautiful thank you man
okay 11.
are you buying stuff now
oh
yeah
um oreos
oh yeah where'd you roll oh this game is
not sponsored by oreos
i'm gonna have some black and white
coming
together creamy filled inside
that was stupid
yeah that was me after all my shows in
new york i mean them the girls
not me
creamy filled inside
yeah
thanks man
according to me filled inside what do
you call asian oreos
they gotta exist
they gotta they gotta i feel like if you
go i like the asian food stores they got
like
their own brand of like she's got six
points now
their own brand oh we need a [ __ ]
everything oreos
cookies throw like
asian cookies uh four tonic way
bow
got three bricks right three bricks good
for you man you're doing great
development card uh it's developmental
card developmental card
when you play this card announce one
type of resource i'm going to say lumber
and all players must give me all their
resources
[Music]
[Music]
here
pit bulls are really getting
more and more audacious
is that like uh
[Music]
they're all talking to each other and
they're like we should amp it up
i just get so many news stories about
people attacks perfect
maybe it's just the algorithm perfect
but then like
a pit bull like
was really getting out of hand today in
front of me
yeah
i don't understand this instrument 12. i
saw a video today
[ __ ]
sad this dude shot his neighbor's
pitbulls running after him it was like a
puppy oh wow
are you sure it was a puppy
you watched so much internet [ __ ] i
watched worldstar man that's
it's trying not good for you no i
thought that a couple times
it's so extreme it's either like super
cute yeah super [ __ ] up exactly i
thought about eight
i thought about that a bunch
because you're always posting those
stories
which ones
on your stories the ones on your stories
that you're posting
because you always like retweet stuff or
you read instagram like i don't post
crazy nasty [ __ ] i'm not no you post
cute [ __ ] you post like great like memes
and stuff oh yeah that's just people you
know like not everything if you if
you're catching that much good content
you're also catching like the downsides
of that however well not on my instagram
just world stars when i get that
negative [ __ ] my story you can scroll
down right now but i can tell like
how sorry deep on the internet you are
by the quality of your memes
there's one i like that i posted it was
like a an animated guy and an animated
girl and they were like laying on their
bed and it was like a cartoon or a comic
book different room scene anyway she's
like
i love how
guys
i love how it's not true that all guys
are only thinking about sex and then he
says laugh out loud okay no i [ __ ] it
up i don't know
nine wow
good story sam what was the end of it i
[ __ ] it up i don't remember it
i love how
sam was like i love how like guys aren't
thinking about sex all the time and that
guy's thinking about sex
yeah that's the premise but the way he
says
yeah
dude i watched a lot of cartoon
porn yesterday and
[Laughter]
you were trying to get away with just
saying cartoon
cartoon
porn um
and there's a lot of like uh
the guy starts kind of raping the girl
oh
i said i i clicked on that i clicked on
top feud so i saw like the most popular
ones and like
uh yeah they're not gonna draw two
people having missionaries could i have
a brick please
i'm still doing my turn oh my god oh my
god i found it the girl says i hate the
stigma that boys only want sex and he
says
i want to stick my balls in your mouth i
don't know that's just funny dude look
because they're their posture
she's like
trying to be all cute yeah
that's that's the type of [ __ ] i post i
mean i don't know i think it's funny
memes
yeah something lumber
i uh with that level of positivity there
has to be an equal and opposite negative
world star that's about world stuff i
don't share that [ __ ] so do you catch
all that stuff on the
oh could i have another brick please i
scroll worldwide
you got that from worldstar no that's
from instagram that's the type i mean i
get my content on my instagram is
totally different than what i look at
like worldstar doesn't
carry over to my instagram
well i saw an american soldier get
sniped by ice that's what i do
here pong showed me this american
soldier gets sniped by isis man when i
got here
well it's combat footage and usually
it's not that usually it's the other way
around yeah seen playing that [ __ ]
dominate like i watch youtube videos
like that sometimes
who has more than seven cards like you
wouldn't be allowed to watch them not me
oh there's plenty of cards do you have
christy how many cards do you have
six
anywhere and cover it up i would suggest
christy because she's winning
uh this is a good spot to [ __ ] her over
no
and to [ __ ] sam over
this would be [ __ ] yourself over yeah
gotcha
okay and then
actually this might have been better
because that's eight this is only
i'm not touching oh actually yeah oh
it's a better spot it just [ __ ] me up
you don't think he's winning
three times four
oh yeah he is sort of winning does
anybody need a sheep anytime
um
no i don't have a rock that might have
been [ __ ] off for more
anyone want sheep
uh yeah for lumber
wait okay
wait
you wait a second sir you wait one
goddamn
rush i'm scared now okay i'll give you
a wheat
a lumber place i don't i regret i
retract mine what about a brick
no i can't
who wants to shave
sheep
brick
or you have a sheep yeah i'll give you a
rock i'll give you a lumber fish thanks
one two anyone at brick
kevin what's this
i need a brick
city on a hill
[Laughter]
i hope i roll seven
[ __ ] six [ __ ]
one two three four all right i will do
oh my god i'm losing
okay i have a trade offer does anyone
have
rock or or whatever you want to call it
what
i'm willing to trade
i'm going to wager i'm willing to wager
i need
three
and i have some stuff what do you need
dude what what is it i have one lumber
no i lied i have a sheep or stone i need
this the rock the four
i would like one brick
i'll give you a brick and a sheep for
three
dude okay two
um
a brick a hay i only have a brick of
sheep to offer
i'll do one for brick
never mind
it's like a i thought about it i know we
went down that rabbit hole i appreciate
it
uh he thinks just because he got your
cards
i'm gonna build a rotor now though
i gotta get off of that
death trap eight that i'm in
[Music]
and then so i built
one why don't you build this side dude
oh i need uh
stop hans i will cut you off twice
you have no shot
[Laughter]
[Music]
i could go like around this [ __ ]
you're gonna go through the
desert possible i mean yeah i mean
you're a 208 now onto it
uh
okay so also
oh i'm two to one
i have
uh you don't have any more i need um
a
lumber i'm i'll trade a hey
a hay for a lumber
or a sheep for a lumber
i'll take the lumber for her hair
no i haven't yeah
dude all right i'm done
some more people are here some horror
people there's more people let's hope so
let's hope so do you order them
dude he cut my thing
off dang
are we going to put a castle right there
oh
jesus
hey the ups guy is here
um
are you still messaging shelby
i am
music band or something oh uh could i
have a lumber or
brick please
yeah for or owl
i don't need something
you have oreo
do you make decisions so slowly
can anyone give me lumber
no
okay
good
dude you're basically just like a twitch
streamer at this point
low quality content
oh i mean this is the content house
wait wait
i need to find the weed what happened to
this right it's right here oh thank you
can i have a sheep for a while oh bro
sheep
it's not that big wait
you literally
an eight
what are you trying to say all right
that these people are really horny
they haven't really been talking about
her except to say that she didn't give
me a ride to the airport
i'm going to build this all right i'm
going to build a city
and build a city here's a dollar
then i'm going to they're saying it's
riley
i was just saying like i got all of this
card
thanks taylor g for giving us a dollar
thanks bud they're saying that 20 cents
each
is it weird that i show them your body
everyone wore bland colors they said
bland orange is bland like orange just
like this
[Music]
that's not gonna work weird compliment
we're just sad because it's winter you
know
actually it was really hot today a
cvs uh lunchroom
yeah it does dude i used to have to be i
just made that one though oh really i
used to have to be in home depot for
tesla and like i would eat lunch in
their lunch room and it was so
depressing with the home depot people
thanks man no problem
this is for you guys
even though you asked me to do this
no one wants you to do drugs well we all
think it's a problem yeah i think it's
it's just like someone with a hair and
addiction i was doing it for you
i want to ask you to
i thought you guys liked it when i was
high what did six
jesus christ that bulls deceptive oh
really
oh yeah sounds weird
it's probably clogged yes
yeah
all that resin good
damn
i can't even smoke weed it these days
here hit this weed pin
yeah
yeah
do you guys like the aziz special
i didn't see it
um i mean it wasn't like great material
i did like the concept of just doing
like a quick half hour and a club i
thought that was pretty cool
but like just to show up oh yeah it
[ __ ] sucked but yeah material wise i
didn't think i was funny dude he's such
a he's so such a pretentious douche well
dude he just looks like he's been
through a lot
he looks like he's really sad yeah he
looks like
i mean he's like i moved to london i got
a flip phone like man
okay
that was really accurate
but he's trying to be like really chill
about it look how cool he is he's
talking about current events and yet
he's still cool about it yeah um
i don't know to me he looks like he's
super sad and like worn down and then
he's doing a good job on top of that
yeah the way he started it was like um
he's like yeah you know i'm just uh you
know you gotta like take some time off
from like playing big theaters you know
you gotta like come back to your roots
and he's like treating the comedy seller
like a little like oh yeah an empty club
yeah he goes he goes
maybe i'm just gonna suck like maybe
this is just gonna suck but who cares
you get to see me like
yeah yeah he's kind of wrong i didn't
say that word for word but like that's
the vibe
but yeah i know and like uh
it was funny like um
it was like he went up at the end of the
show or it's just like everyone wants
it's like all right guys i know i said
that was the end of the show but now uh
this guy's gonna come through 30 minutes
of comedy yeah
and oh you guys should be excited it's
probably like it's probably like 2 30 in
the yeah i know like but but granted in
new york they stay up till like five in
the morning on wednesday night and they
oh i didn't hear that part
yeah the guy who introduced him he's
like i know what i told you
this guy was the last comic book we got
that's you never know what you're
getting at the con the comedy cellar
yeah
because they just go from show to show
to show so you know you don't know if
that was that's true you're right it's
true it probably wasn't probably because
you probably didn't show up at 2am like
it's not going to be something david
tell does it just show up like that
would be stupid because the yeah
what is this it's trash
no it's not it's yeah
it smells really good it smells like
cinnamon
this is nice i like smudging
hey guys uh make sure to leave a five
dollars
um if you want
to keep this show running
all right we already got one dollar
for
a fifth of the wedding
nice it was worth it
thanks tyler g for the dollar
damn what the [ __ ] is that conversion
can i have some
i've been drinking my own pee
nice frothy sarah i mean clearly it's
not working well because you're clearly
dehydrated
yeah
well i was sick yesterday
sick with it
no it's pronounced stick with it i was
like i think like omicron again
yesterday oh cool thanks for coming
you're not it'd be weird it's like
because i already had omicron so i don't
know why i got sick again
it's a new update you can't say yes it's
so soft
1.3
i don't know
too bad i can't get tested
why not because i like tried ones in
like all the locations said no
appointments available ever
as well ever
ever i'm serious yeah seriously guys
never ever
no appointments ever
available ever that's ridiculous i just
got tested there's they're out they're
free on the side of the road like on
south tomorrow they have one you just
pull up
when like this is how long does it take
i was in another ten minutes there
wasn't a line so i was pretty cool yeah
they just have a qr code that you like
to scan and then you just register while
you're in line and then you just drive
through them
dude once they test you they're like all
right get out of here we'll send you the
results they text you or you might
say super quick
this was two days ago i just got tested
uh
wait is it my turn you didn't go yet
yeah i did
okay i roll the six okay seven hell yeah
let's go
how many cards you guys got guys
okay i gotta get rid of some [ __ ]
five six no i have seven let's go
man to be honest
you always helped a new person
all right i got some uh
i need ore
i'll give two hay for one ore
so let's go too late i didn't do
anything i fell asleep
at the court near me there's a nice
court near our house really though
better than the one that we played at
remember it's like the children's is
like near the dog park oh yeah it's
better
better it was way better yeah we didn't
know about it back then yeah we
discovered it recently but i've done it
it's um what did you play with
it's by that like 7-11
but um four just like jack's uh brothers
are in town and like
nice
jack's family is so funny can anyone
give me wood are they all short
no he's actually
he's a funny guy too
jack yeah
yeah
but uh his dad is really funny like i
open the door
he's like knocking it's like 8 30 a.m
and i see him i was like oh you must be
mr timmy
and uh and he's like smoking cigar he's
like is jack ready i told that [ __ ]
[ __ ] to be ready
that [ __ ] better
get his [ __ ] act together
it's just like holy [ __ ] this is a live
stream it's a four
yeah i mean
he's a umpire right for baseball
yeah
i'm sure he's good at comedy he has a
positive outlook on life
he's able to be good at lots of
different things
okay i'm gonna play my development card
it's the knight that's why i remove the
robber that's why jackman looks like
he's wearing this i know no
they're like the first day he was wait
wait you know what i was gonna
he always looks like he's wearing
baseball pants yeah
well he's like kristy give me some
resources
she holds them up and you get the
pictures but she's always wearing like
you get to pick like i'm moving i played
my
[Music]
[Music]
i played at night
yeah
what are you gonna say yeah
and then build that room uh yeah like i
saw there you go yeah
jack like the person who's
just a baseball player yeah
wow that's weird i mean granted he was
golfing
build a city
but uh
who wants to order pizza
yeah
you just kind of sit around you kind of
stand around like whoa whoa there it
went
no that's not how you play baseball
though where it went oh there we go
when you have to run like oh hold on you
run to the like the base what do you
mean
yeah they don't do anything anybody want
to trade some brick for you swinging 100
an hour
[Music]
you should just start playing baseball i
feel like you've played this before
those dudes no i'm never playing this is
my first oh you're telling him all the
rules he's like he's kind of scared he's
like
people are like throwing it really
[ __ ] someone's donated
my ex-boss like
no it's not oh yeah it's gotta be
continuous
one two three four five six seven one
two three four five six seven i guess
okay and you just built this so it was
like this okay so you were at six so she
was winning okay you tied
yeah cool but if you want to build
another road you can
take it back
christie's at nine points now start to
build another road damn
okay rusty is orange one two three four
five six seven yeah she's at nine points
okay
they're both in
well if i could build can i build
another road before i pass yeah oh okay
then i'll build another road before i
pass
next
i built another road and beat your
longest road so i took your what did you
roll i rolled the four it was a long
time
yeah
seven
let's go
let's go brandon
what a great i'm glad that that happened
in history good
it's such a great just like
[ __ ] yeah
just like it's so like
innocent sounding let's go brandon but
it has like such a more
like when did you roll funnier meaning
yeah like if you were out of the no and
someone was like saying that as an
inside joke you would be like i don't
know why are you picking [ __ ] up you
rolled a four right no i rolled the
seven oh oh yeah i mean what does that
even mean
like how does that even get into this
was it a nascar race she's like how do
you know
i don't know guys that's uh
yo so this nascar race and this
interviewer chick is uh interviewing the
racer just one and uh
his name was brandon
and she like saved it because in the
background the whole audience is saying
[ __ ] joe biden
[ __ ] joe
and then she's like yeah you can hear
them now they're saying let's go brandon
and then they get cuts kind of shortly
after that that's so funny that uh if
that term was a nascar race that oh yeah
it's very on brand for sure seven seven
elizabeth you
had to put the sheep down for that
development i uh put down two wheat
which substitutes for a sheep because i
have a port it's funny how about
like
um republicans and democrats like each
of their own diets
like
like uh conservatives don't like
fluoride and like democrats don't like
gluten
he's like why can't you all just agree
to be like healthy
you don't have to have your own thing
like your own
it's like a window
yeah it's like but like i don't think
anyone wants chloride in their body
i like those are just like you guys are
just being cool what are multiple bricks
so if you talk about it positively then
gluten might not be a big deal
i don't think gluten's uh very good
let's go
sorry
do you need that one no i got a bunch
more okay
i don't get any of those those are rare
oh my god
oh he [ __ ]
did it dude
you're about to have cedar fever bro
that's how you do it in austin i just
love vaccines
that's
[Music]
you pass it like this
not like this
yeah
oh
[Music]
[Music]
that's pretty much ash
uh
it's right there on here so i moved the
robber piece i'm not doing [ __ ] actually
i'll trade a uh
i need lumber i have a hay so you might
want to do that see what you got
i got a hay for lumber no
no so well
all right then i will pass the die oh
yeah let's go
let's go
they're having their own uh conversation
in the comments what are they saying
who did you guys include us in the
conversation
john rice we're less cool than the chat
who has more than seven we're having
lessons
dude i rolled seven
that's so annoying three seven
show list
i have a podcast about movies i love
each movie but i like both of them have
you heard his bit about jesus he's from
another time give me one of your
resources
except he's not like uh political social
media
okay
i don't know much about it well yeah i
mean uh sorry that not everyone's such a
centrist like you
whoa dude
checking clouds
nine
nine is fine dude you want some water
yes i [ __ ] you over
i'm good thank you
yes
i mean i love that bit i think he might
overdo it on the performance but it's
well written as a joke
they said quit staring at us
dude you guys aren't even here
trying to
look at the comments
[Laughter]
cool
cool
how many cards do you have yeah let's go
brand new
did you
you have one seven i didn't six now i
have seven i'm not trying yeah
shit's about to give you you're winning
so i'm like
i feel like you duped us dude
first time i ever looked played in a
poker tournament like ever played poker
i won that too so don't you ever play
the lottery oh wow
that makes me pay you even more
i mean you're winning and it's your
first time and then you say well
actually i'm really good at things
[Laughter]
without even trying or ever playing
anymore i am a master how was i supposed
to make it better
well this is like a first what should
you win
i want like 190 bucks nice
but uh
where was it
this is a friend's house
this it the high stakes table yeah
the caesars i know i was like 190
yeah here's a five dollar thing
my first time on world series of poker
stealing from
who's winning oh you're winning yeah
still away
taylor g.s if you have a six-pack please
say yes me yes yeah sepaglia
i i used to have a six-pack
well
what until i drank it
i just haven't been working out that
much
yeah ever since you
had a more comfortable life
i just haven't had access to a gym
i'd love to jim it up
um but yeah i mean
i haven't living in this house five
it's really addicting right i never
wanted to leave my
apartment it's not that addicting
like after i got out of a show instead
of going to other things i would be like
dude i have an apartment full of food
and like alcohol yeah and so i just like
go back as fast as i could then you're
not at bars at open mics just being like
hey guys yeah i'm not like socializing
this is better than just going to my car
yeah exactly
yeah that's in that way it's good to
live in your car you just rush into
every building yeah does anyone want to
trade i have a world differently i need
a brick so you want to have an extra
brick it also like forces you out
it forces you to like be out and about
yeah
i remember like looking out at the trees
from the 23rd floor of my apartment
i was looking out at the horizon and i
was like i wanna i can't build this with
that building i want to go hiking and i
was like emotionally
i knew i couldn't get to the trees
before i was gonna build one here but i
can't do that without building a
settlement right
um
yeah i think that's right
yeah that spot
on your story today looks really cool
thanks dude it's like right next to my
house i'm gonna get tired of it though
if it's right in my house
oh yeah it's my where my car is parked
next to the gym that you
bathe at eight yeah
they have a lot of homeless people now
um
finally
you know what's also good about katan is
that everyone plays till the end six
like it's not like poker where people
lose and they have to sit out yeah oh
yeah when the game's over it's over
yeah yeah i get that yeah i like i
appreciate that too it makes it like no
one wants to play for third place
like really who wants a hay
i'll take a guy
pay for or
interesting
um
wait nick won
already
yeah
one one two
that's eight
no plus the two victory cards damn he
did win longest round finish he has the
longest
road cool yeah
we almost went a whole turn around
before we noticed there what did you
build you built this city that's even
worse he's like oh i didn't know i won
and we're like you won he's like oh cool
that's funny what is uh you really need
to chill out
with like how you're pressuring the game
[Laughter]
sorry guys yeah that's funny what if we
go to like a beautiful like kind of
bougie place
and we play dice there
oh
what the
dice we like sit down and we like enjoy
the scenery and the people
and we just [ __ ]
you like we start hooting and hollering
yeah you put like a couple of put money
in the circle you like roll dice and
whoever rolls the most like wins all the
money in the circle and you keep going
[Music]
we're going to have to make it a bigger
one if we just go look at denny's and
they're just starting how did you know
that that already sounded trashy
because you've been explaining it for
three times
comparing poker if we were playing poker
that's like
that's classy
like everyone's like this
the whole box
someone said riley looks depressed
are you
yeah
what's this whole thing
they're
[Music]
[Music]
he is
[Music]
i'll take some so one more we'll get rid
of this [ __ ] thank you
let's order some [ __ ] pizzas
where is it gonna sound so positive
though it's like golem
yeah i mean all you can see is like a
tropical
monster
yeah it's just like the bougie with dice
game
uh yeah
okay you're like the loch ness monster
tropical in the dark
[Music]
you're quick
[Music]
[Music]
more burritos
[Music]
i love burritos i love burritos better
than tacos i do too but like the only
place i found a burrito is that the taco
truck at the tiniest bar
it's pretty good though the halal the
burrito oh the burrito tennis bar you
thought so that was good the one i got
was
they gave me three burritos ones for
free
free burrito yeah it was a fat day
because they were closing i got cash for
the pizza
pizza does order from what's the deal
that you were talking about riley the
triple threat trio he's he's got his ear
on the ground
i saw the commercial
comes natural to the whites
the corporation
they're like tapped into the system
the corporation just operates his uh
place for it and put it over here
so uh what was it the triple
no
the range regained
is it like a whole cartoon to this
it's the triple pet trio the rager game
[Music]
keep reading their roasts make a song
out of it
can you do it do you want to do it on
the computer triple threat
[Music]
is
brought to you by oreos and pizza
dude
what if i make some ramen for you guys
would you eat that
there's like a lot of ramen here
dude what about empanadas there's
empanadas here i could make
those are your pot stickers right
yeah
what you want to eat like a bunch of my
food is that your food i'd rather eat a
pizza i uh
i always eat what i eat i want to eat
something different that's not your food
though or you're taking it
it is your food
there that's all my food
i don't want to eat that
yeah i know i want to eat pizza hut i
love pizza what's wrong with that can i
make a ramen for myself
actually i don't want to sorry
i don't know you didn't give me a ride
to the airport
[Music]
at least we're talking it out
yeah
yes we are
you know i don't get to meet like tons
of new friends like you do so it hurts a
little bit more when a friend like
drops off the map
well i mean you did uh
is that the ultimate roast to be wait
why don't you
have a lot of friends you could you just
choose not to
i mean uh i'm not blowing up
and also i have high standards
well lower your standards
okay
so that i don't have to hang out with
you anymore
it's fun
it's just like
never have sex
that's cool
but yeah
[Music]
i want to sexually assault you
verbally
uh what'd you say that you want to
sexually accept
no i said i don't i don't want to like
bring it up and be like a super intel
about it yeah oh good try to avoid that
good
um
[Music]
how do you do this can you do this
um
speak to your overlords pizza hut
order
what do you want new spicy lovers pizza
three trailblazing pizza that i bring
the heat with the spicy flavor that
hungry honestly i'm starving
you get the triples for trio
original stuffed crust large one topping
it's 13 bucks what is the triple threat
about this where is the triple threat
come in
it's like a dessert and two pizzas she
don't think they have it anymore
[Laughter]
i think
i just saw a commercial
it was only for one time
like the szechuan sauce from rick and
morty
sauce
i'm just gonna do this one
delivery
log into facebook
that's where that gets you dude it's
like
no continuous is that oh it says
creating a kit oh my god
pizza hut
come on
take my facebook
oh i have to put an address in
i don't want to be orange again
does anybody else you want brown
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't like white because it's harder
to see i like white film
it's like the snowy out do you think the
great white sharks are like the white
people of the ocean
the black people of the ocean no that
makes sense
dolphins are the white people that's
what makes sense yeah yeah oh i thought
they were the black people
who are the black people of the ocean
great white sharks
you gotta get some tuna
they're still
dude i thought about tuna
you say that black people were the great
white sharks
yeah
[ __ ] just what's the uh
the shark from nemo hey that man
bruce
yeah yeah but what if the black people
are hammerhead sharks
because they're more aggressive or
something oh
christy come on
relax uh i rolled
a lot a line
man
uh
chrissy's turn
dang so you're like
dang son
that's such a she's going first
so no you roll
all right try to shuffle it up a little
bit more
i roll again no he does
sorry
not 12.
so it's christy's turn
you guys rolling
you roll
yeah i forgot
okay what a twelve
okay
i'm like more higher than you yeah
i wanted to do you think you're more
good on that
okay you're more on it moronic
yeah your turn
to put your house down
put your own down too
christy put your road down
yeah we all know you are
but people need to know
but there's actually a lot more [ __ ]
people than we've seen
what are you doing
what he's a little bit [ __ ]
no i'm talking about like the majority
of people like that's why they
you know you think the majority watch
football games all day long hell yeah
brother oh yeah
yeah we're gonna watch the football game
oh
but there's a difference between being
dumb like uneducated and being [ __ ]
like some people are just no dude
naturally [ __ ] yes
dude i was like so slow
like you know
my teachers were kind of bad and stuff
but like something in me pushed me to
like to like try to get further you know
what i mean and it didn't push them
so many people were never pushed um from
the inside
you know
but that's not being that's not what
being [ __ ] is that's what they
[ __ ] is all about these people watch
football all sunday
literally all sunday they're watching it
and like somebody like me my iq
pushes me after the first game and i'm
like we can't keep doing this okay guys
break
circle time
yeah
and it doesn't happen to them
[Music]
they're just like keep it going
the next maybe they're going through a
lot of things in their mind
that are beautiful and
green like flowers
yeah
isn't that what's going through your
mind when you like record yourself
singing
first of all i don't
you're like lip-syncing
oh yeah
no i just get really inspired by a song
and i can't help but do it
like i can help it yeah no everybody
else can help it except that's beautiful
yeah yeah a lot of people um
really like shane
dude we need to get we need to get like
better at take top dancing
are you getting better at tick tock
dancing yeah that's like one of my
resolutions here oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
what if you try to compete to be like so
bad that you go viral
is to be so bad at tick-tock dancing
that it's like hilarious but plenty of
people are already terrible dude let's
try to do that
you have to do it really you have to do
it in great quality like filming you
have film quality like technically be so
good because like you just portray it
badly yeah yeah so you know we always
become master dancers yeah like you'd
have to be doing like full like
different dances for like different
songs you know like you'll see hammer
dances where the song doesn't go with it
or something you know
you have to memorize the dance that they
have and then do that badly
yeah
it sounds like a lot of work you guys
check out crayon pop
wait that's you
yes
what the funds came in the hands can
find
what is this
holy [ __ ] bro
where is this what is the context for
this
[Laughter]
there's no sound which
[Laughter]
oh no don't shoot wow that guy's good
what the [ __ ]
this is so then you did this the crazy
thing is the girls are in the background
doing the same
dance like a projected image
they're doing it this needs to be shown
to the world
are you waiting for my time
let's do this
we should do this again that's really a
lot of choreography
[Music]
[Laughter]
like this was like reverse what song is
it playing
dude like this was like um
it took you weeks to memorize right yeah
a year a year
is this like for an actual competition
no it's just like a variety show
it's like stand-up storytelling
we were doing it anyways and we just
wanted to find a venue for it
it was just as good without the music
like almost like just what are we
watching like
yeah dude maybe you still remember that
choreography you can do that oh i'm sure
he does he learned it from all right
i named my hands five though oh man yeah
are they your friends
yeah some of them yeah you had to learn
the dance with them for like a year
[Music]
so like wow
yeah which one did you but the hardest
part is getting in sync with everybody
that's why it's probably the worst oh
really yeah dude that guy's not worthy
of being in the on-screen
yeah he's uh yeah i mean this guy wasn't
too good at it
it's just funny because even if it's bad
it's like funny that's funny i did it no
for sure uh also it's different for one
person learning that dance than like
five and sing
people dude was it meant to be funny
yeah okay
oh thank god
hans used to do interpretive dance like
it was critical
for this specific episode this feeling
was was it for school just get some [ __ ]
just get some shirts made to say crayon
pop and never talk about it it just wear
it on stage like the next time you put
it in my car
yeah that could go viral if you did it
right for
sure wait
you have to wait for the right time to
drop that that's like six months with
the content like for sure like that's so
funny
yeah you can put that into little tick
tocks and make 20 tick tocks of
that can just start a challenge and have
people learn to dance and
tag your whatever hashtag you make
okay whose turn is it mine you can start
a variety show uh who wants to be in the
hans kim five and you see
submit that out and people have to learn
it
and then they send you their like self
tapes of auditioning
what are you doing then
zooming out
it looks the same
it's not a delay it's darker oh
stop sneaking away and moving back so
far
dude well i mean that's i'm not doing
that on purpose
she's scoot at the shirt we can scoot
over a little bit chrissy slide it a
little bit
please all right fine i got tons of guys
if i go that way this thing is in my
right hand oh okay
i'll get you no no
oh yeah
yeah i can hide in plain sight
uh who wants to blending into the walls
i'm blending into my environment
who's transitioning
i don't know
where are you going i'm gonna put my
house down
you have one down
we have we have to put two down
you got any uh
anything left in that grinder
oh sorry
[Music]
uh so
i was the last one so i go twice
technically right that's me now
[Music]
that's my fault it's my [ __ ] down
already
[Music]
you farted
who farted is that what you're just
saying no oh i said
i
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh
where have you masturbated in here
gross oh sorry i don't do that kind of
stuff
so hans have you been hooking up with
the ladies
yeah just before you guys came i was
fingering a girl
oh whoa wow
hans that's it
[Music]
yeah
and everyone's a stud muffin you ever
take your finger out and lick it
no
i don't i don't want to do that
why are you scared
yeah i like juicing
well i don't i like a lot of stuff i
don't have to taste it
i like cars i feel like monsters
this is like i was telling how i was
really
like
no way does it i i had no
idea uh assuming that it didn't
did you actually i didn't know if it was
new or not i've never seen it before i
mean i've only been over a couple times
it definitely makes you take a second
glance like that
yeah
but when i'm holding it no because it's
also like
it's like silicone so it's like yeah i
know that's very phallic it's that
pinkish color
it's honestly smart because it makes
girls like
think about ulterior like
situations
girls love to think about ulterior
situations rather than men girls i think
prefer dildos at this point so if you
like have dildos around they're like oh
whoa
oh he's not gonna he's gonna penetrate
me
[Music]
[Laughter]
want to be is it my turn entered this
turn yeah it's true though that's funny
that's awesome
i'm glad that my bong makes people want
to be violated yeah i feel bad violated
like i'm violating when i hold it i got
so high just now
yeah
um
whose turn i
put my house down
everyone needs two houses
the green guy oh i lied
[Music]
well she went first twice so it threw me
off
uh okay yeah she went first twice that
makes a lot of sense
[Music]
she has two she's supposed to go last
but she already has her house done
dude that's such a good point that like
i i like a lot of things that i don't
taste that i don't have to taste yeah
i like vaginas i just don't want to have
to like
i like cars but i don't taste those you
need to remember that because i think
tony's going to ask you that exact
question well no he's not should we not
talk about place time business
listening yeah can you not talk about
tony because you act crazy around them
what
like remember when we were all on the
bench and then you sat down next to
sailor
tennis yeah and the bench shook them and
then you were like ugh
i was i do this a lot everywhere and you
were just like acting like
like you're up to no good yeah i had a
lot of anxiety at that time like i was
trying to give up alcohol and also doing
alcohol at the same time
what a contradiction
yeah because what it is is you try to
give it up but you have so much anxiety
that you still drink it at the end of
the day
yeah i mean maybe you could just try to
work on it yeah i mean i have a lot less
anxiety now
thank god yeah
thanks for helping me
you're so welcome yeah
riley and i were there for you so yeah
we're good friends
sometimes
but we're not feeling sad but tony is
kind of judgmental you have to
yeah that's why he's good at what he
does so you can't be like just yourself
around him
um yeah
you can be yourself around them in fact
your quiet self around them
yeah i mean sometimes i'm quiet like
what's wrong with being quiet americans
have to be loud all the time where they
feel they'll disappear but if you're
always afraid then you're never
are you loud around him sometimes yeah
that sounds like
tony you are so funny
yeah
can you say that in like that hollywood
voice
all right i gotta go see you
you just haven't
enough
good to see you guys
oh my god how's the house
how's the kids
i finished up that pilot
i'll tell you this guy don't get this
guy around sushi
oh nice
cool
yeah i just started tanning
[Laughter]
actually i probably would have done it
before then
it's a better uh does that fly me to the
moon
[Music]
[Music]
especially on saturday
they don't even care about this yeah
dude you know they think the liquor
stores they close at like 10 or
something oh yeah
no just every saturday the liquor stores
close at 10 p.m yeah i do don't know
they don't open till monday
and uh oh because of saturday tomorrow
sunday they close at 10 on saturday
which is weird without a respect the
lord yeah dear heavenly father
we won't be drinking this weekend this
sunday on the day of the lord's day we
do
repent hallelujah i said amen
i said praise be attackers
packers dear lord if you could help my
wife's sweet ass stay in shape and
god bless texas
in jesus name
we fire guns
did you get did you guys
you guys sit through the skeptic tank
video with joe rogan and tony
hinchcliffe why do you say it like that
i'm just asking you guys it looks like a
cool pusher
yeah nice gun ranch yeah
the only reason i don't like austin is
just like they're i don't have enough
money to be doing cool [ __ ] like that
and awesome
yeah it's like like capitalism rich
people like always say austin is cool
it's like now like i kind of see what
they're saying it's just like there's
[ __ ] that i just like can't afford
that's like awesome to do
yeah
there's giraffes all over i can't like
experience texas without like having
like rich texas yeah well you can you
can just like you know
be entertaining to
some rich people that will want you
around
and then i mean it's their private ranch
yeah
[Music]
that's one way i've been to a ranch
just family friendly they have ranch
this one was like
some of those people just had crazy
money
they can afford really good ranch
truffle wrench
oh my god that sounds so good
but um
i think that like uh one large pizza for
us should be good
yeah i'm down
um
what do you want to get i'm pretty open
to anything
i like everything
supreme pepperoni
[ __ ] can we have a vegan plea a vegan
pizza
not from domino then we can't get cheese
uh memphis barbecue chicken county bacon
ranch pacific veggie
men's extravaganza but deluxe i feel
like i say like cream or wine
what was that extravaganza did you see
that it's rainbow
it's like mushrooms oh olives damn look
at all that i'm down with that the
supreme pizza is good everyone i think i
like that
yeah some people don't like
extra
stuff you can we can do half and half
you like us if it's a supreme yeah
because it has everything it has the
meats it's not just order now
uh
continue
but i'm also open to other [ __ ] too i'm
just saying
red view why don't we just get a little
bit of everything
every single store
you know there's like no chinese
restaurants
in austin that's true man i try to get a
good generous
housing yeah
sorry we can't there's some good ones by
youtube
hey
can you go make ramen
yeah yeah uh
it was like really soft last time i
don't know if there's like a better way
to make it than what usual you know like
it cooked quickly but then it was like a
little tin
i'll do it
are you gonna be mad
just turn it on
i'll boil the water
it was cooking on low you don't leave it
on boiling no dude you're gonna you one
time you made me ramen and it was the
softest ramen i've ever had
is that a good thing no
i like ramen to be like
well yeah i mean i was doing it on a
campfire yeah i know
let's see so who's playing
who's gonna get
[Music]
um
i just put my second one down
so now we're starting rolling here
oh you want to do that yeah let's just
do that there's italian sausage red
pepper and there's
four meat
yes
okay number two what is it for number
four
for me that's like me tonight yeah yes
and a side of fries
i'll please hush puppies if you got
something
did i get a sprite was that a slave
reference did you say hush puppies can
you know what those puppies are yeah
that's what slaves invented to like
prevent dogs from attacking well it's
just what they call they're just corn
balls with like corn sleep and jalapenos
sometimes they're delicious maybe you
shouldn't have so much hostility towards
you get angry at french fries because
it's not technically fun
i think she just really cares about
slaves
yeah but what a weird time to bring it
up like i'm talking about food
[Music]
hey what do you guys think being
[ __ ] is all about dude let's throw a
lot of kimchi on top of this pizza no
have you ever put kimchi on your pizza
that was insane since i was
producing i thought it would be good on
french fries though damn
[Music]
yeah just do the
okay
uh whose turn is it
christie's in there
okay
did you not roll
no
oh hey you [ __ ] another thing up
eight
is that what it was
yesterday
[ __ ] dude i so [ __ ] up
are you [ __ ] up or are you so [ __ ]
up
can i have a brick please forever
you want a brick yeah
you have an oar i like it i am down
you should preheat the oven before you
do anything six
six
let me win once
okay
400.
i still want to make the robin
good idea
um
going counterclockwise now
two
like whoa
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
for
[Music]
um
six
no not yet
it's going so fast
it's all happening so fast
ah
eight
samsung
oh i did
so do you think that
stand-up comedy is uh
like worth it
it's like a lot
bridgette fantasy was like people were
like you know pressuring me and it was
like a negative atmosphere so i went to
online thank god i did now i'm rich and
famous and i was like ah
what are the best comedy specials during
the pandemic
[Music]
i don't know dude
norman uh oh yeah
[Music]
oh that was so good oh really
that was recent
[Music]
[Music]
it is a pandemic it hurts me like it's i
get sick constantly i'm just like about
nobody's treating it like
whether it is or not
no one thinks it's a pandemic because
it's not it's a pandemic
it's not like
what do you guys think is worse
coming 11.
[Music]
[Music]
uh but 9 11 happened quick and it was
sad it was like oh people hate us damn
they really don't like us yeah yo what
the [ __ ] but then it was like then it
turned into anger and it became
dissipated but this is just like ugh
and then everyone's fighting each other
yeah and i like
get sick so often now
because i didn't get the vaccine and i
think there's something happening thanks
for coming
dude i get sick pretty often too
yeah
so why'd you just laugh at me like
no it just sounded funny
uh if i was like draw someone i get sick
very often four
you would draw riley more than me right
yeah
yeah
four
if i get my own glass
in the washing machine
[Music]
does anybody want to trade um some
lumber for some brick
lumber lumber i have lumber
i don't need lumber i'm sorry i
have two lumber for two burn
or one for one
thank you
i'll do uh
a ore for
[Music]
[Music]
dollars he's a puppet dude that's how
much it costs again austin
if you go no if you go to a restaurant
and get a kombucha i mean i think he's
trying his best
who wants wood
is that a critical thing to say yeah who
has brick would you roll
12.
no one wants brick
did white get her two sheep
thanks
is that how you talk to white girls
hello white woman did white get addicted
yet
do you want my [ __ ]
hello
hello
there's life like this
is white
[Music]
think asian people are hungry than white
people
i think they're more involved in some
ways did you guys not in surviving a
genocide
are y'all allergic to corn at all
corn yeah let's go i don't think an
entire race of species can be like
allergic to something yeah a lot of
asians are lactose
intolerant yeah milk alcohol yeah
and like yeah they're evolved
it's like aliens like people that are
evolved further are allergic to the
things that we have to get rid of
they're allergic to gluten i mean like
native americans and alcohol
they don't have the enzyme so he just
[ __ ] them up it's like a dmt pen all
the time for real yeah
i'm 11 native american i know i can tell
yeah you look native american
no but it doesn't
i mean it feels good to be on alcohol
yeah a little too good you should start
smoking tobacco
[Music]
you should not eat a lot of sugar
because you'll balloon up real quick
yeah i know i would watch out for
syphilis
yeah try not to get small pox
that was
pretty brutal
yeah all the latina girls like you
skipped me
that was very
i wasn't so confident that i was like oh
okay yeah i was not snoozing oh wait i
actually already went
are you serious
six
of my [ __ ] i think i got a wood
i'll give you a wood
you're red red red red red red neck yeah
you got a little i gave it
no i didn't
uh i got a sheep for a brick
i got a fence for your kite i'll give a
sheep if someone has a brick they'd be
willing i got trees
brick
hans you want to get rid
[Music]
okay
z-roll
set a timer for 26 minutes
uh yeah i roll the nine starting now
oh let's go
[Music]
wow you're doing great brother
[ __ ] you
i see it coming along
oh could i please have a break for
anything
brick
anyone no
[Music]
correct i don't have any pranks
should i take this
yeah they got two one
it was like right here
i gave you one he gave me one yeah yeah
it was the one that was face up or face
down right there yeah
one two three four
five six seven all right your turn
[Music]
so
remember the time that uh
that one i had to go render that video
friend drinks tasty was there
what the hell
i don't know price of six street blues
is the him
is it a naked video of me
yeah it totally is it's you get a train
by hans kim in the house
[Music]
dude you know the way that they've been
talking about putting out another
candidate anybody want to trade
no i need kanye's just like i'm going to
put out another kim song
i don't have that it's really mean
yeah you shouldn't do that
old sex tapes and i'm going to put it
out
[Music]
he's like threatening to put it out
[Music]
dude he'll do anything look at his face
dude he'll literally drink
really it's not true what if it's like
oh yeah dude you know what i watched
yesterday
the pamela anderson sex tape like i had
never seen it oh yeah i watched it it
was it was interesting
there's a couple though dude brett
michaels pissed me off the whole time
what a dude it wasn't brett michaels yes
it was no it's not it's tom tommy lee
but they said brett
for the whole thing uh
i think she has a couple porn videos
honestly yeah the famous one was tommy
lee [ __ ] her on this boat
oh i need to find that that's a good one
yeah let's watch it it's a good one okay
but yeah so brett michaels just kept
saying like suck my dick like he just
kept saying that like oh he's definitely
doing that for the camera
yeah
i thought he didn't talk to that though
too but yeah for the camera for sure he
just seemed like
not even good
he was a sex icon back in the day
dude i saw his dating show
oh yeah he's he's washed up now that's
why he has a dating show but like back
when he was like
killing it he was crying ladies were
like
it's like oh yeah that guy would be like
an attention-grabbing
cartoon like person
lemon
so [ __ ] pissed who wants wood
i do
you have sheep
yes i have a sheep you have rock
no
what about wheat for a rock
what the [ __ ] i wanted wood for a sheep
i need a rock
okay i have a rock okay i have a rock
sheep i mean i want what
okay
please two
two for two two for two
wow
god
okay
but what were you trying to bring up
earlier was it important
yeah i remember 6th street blues we
should do that again
i just get afraid of the violence
oh the violence i forgot about the
violence
yeah
but i like it when you get kisses and
stuff like that that's like cool
it'd be it like that sounds fun to push
people you got to push that on everyone
i mean i think we're in a very kissing
mood it could be a film of me like
pressing people's heads against yours
and being like
like it sounds like assault
what you just kissed me
no sorry i should have said that that's
sexual assault
yeah now you're in positions of power so
now you have to be like more and more
goddamn
cancel
dude i saw it like uh i don't care one
of the biggest like hype house guys
dude you guys need to care more about
this stuff but like i pass he finally
put out a video
uh
it like um
accusing this girl cnn who's another
huge person of sexual assault for a
whole year
oh yeah she assaulted him while he was
sleeping well he finally put out a video
being like this the title is sick the
title of the video is this is what santa
may did to me and he like talks him is
that a real person or it sounds like
like minnie mouse well it's like her
name on tick-tock sienna gomez but like
uh
it's wild he just sits there and accuses
her of so many things
yeah building a road in a zone
it's like be careful
because
you know the internet is real
yeah and she i mean dude if you watch
all the videos like it seems like
he was kind of flirtatious so i don't
know are you just saying that because
he's good looking
i mean he like he would like kiss her on
the cheek all the time and stuff it's
like
i'm sure she was rough and overconfident
with him but like
that's not really sexual assault like he
acts like she's a monster she's like
planning she can do whatever she wants
because
she does her on the cheeks
yeah she doesn't respect boundaries does
anyone have any ore they want to get rid
of for lumber
personality
you have or i have number uh
[ __ ] dude have you all ever had that
though where like there's a girl that
like she just doesn't respect boundaries
she's overconfident with you
and so she like you tell her no and
she's like nah the answer is yes
yeah yeah i lost my virginity
i'm like true
so overconfident like girls don't feel
the need to keep asking consent at every
stage i didn't care though i just think
the answer is yes
yeah because there are they're the
feeling correctly you can't argue with
their feelings
did i
roll yeah
okay
this
is
your three points
[Music]
damn
thanks
does anyone have hay
i have or i have or for hay
jorge
[Music]
bring
[Music]
um
i'm worried about my hair
oh no not the hair
okay he's going bald
snow stop
don't tell them
also it might not be true
[Music]
i know visual thinking never got anyone
anywhere
nine
and i'm worried about my long neck
neck i like my neck
anybody have any bricks or trees
actually not i don't really care about
my neck
yeah just don't leave it exposed it
helps me
[Music]
oh sorry
all right
so what was the video that you were
rendering
there's six street fighters
there used to be six but great
rendering is the nerdiest word
when you say rendering it's like the
nerdiest sound
right
now you have to wait for it to render
like you're immediately the most nervous
that's what video editing is
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
that was a little extra
all right
[Music]
dude i can't believe you fell for it
like a [ __ ] loser dude
do you did i mess up the thing yeah
i think we're all right pretty much
it's okay so you should have been there
at aviator nation
how'd the show go
[Music]
am i good
it was a lot of children
beautiful beautiful children
i mean
[Music]
they're all young they're like 20s
that's cool
yeah so they laughed easy or not
they're all right they were good okay
they were they were interesting
they were honest
yeah
they were who they were did they kiss
you
yeah 17 of them did you go over it yes
give me that that's yours is that
no
i didn't kiss anyone
thanks for asking
nine it's like laying the dice not
rolling the dice dude i mean i wasn't
doing it on purpose
[Music]
nine
i like nine though that's good i got
stuff
who wants rock
uh
i do you have wheat
no i have number
sheep
what about everyone do well one rock
some people did it's hard to tell like
some people i thought did badly some
other people were like they were my
favorite so i was like i don't know what
do you want a rock for what for two wood
[Music]
i'll do a rock for one
i need
it cost you dearly
one two three four yeah man i mean
that's just like the best show to get
booked for because like you get
do you don't you get like free merch i
got 300 worth of free merch from aviator
nation it's like this cool like retro
stuff yeah their jackets are really nice
yeah i should have used it on a jacket
yeah dude that's the thing we're invited
to remember my friend mason
at one time that's like where his
girlfriend works oh it probably mattered
eight
oh yeah you did
why are they always talking about me
i mean i'm not a little self-centered
just get me just crop me out
stop trying to escape
dude if the ramen is in there at all
it's cooked thanks
sorry
you're not japanese you're not japanese
yes
i know
i potentially know just as much
dude
sometimes
[Music]
i got it for christmas my mom wanted
like family photos with like my my niece
and all that stuff so i was like all
right so i haven't since when it's cold
they're warm they're good they're good
pajamas
i'd rather a one piece
seems cozy i mean i i have a pair too my
mom anywhere but they're like one thing
some of them got the glass yeah i like
the flap i had one where it like slowed
down just above my dick so i had to like
like yeah some of them were down some of
them
like a girl who bent over but yeah
like
sorry rompers are sometimes nice
they look comfortable remember when the
dude robbers were trying to be a thing
like two years ago
i mean not here
not here but all over the world people
wear that [ __ ]
yeah but
yeah i felt like the romp handles what
the name of the brain was robbed him
yeah it was like
it was like men's rompers i prefer
onesie like it's so funny like how men's
marketing is always just like tells that
it's like for us it's like this is this
for men so yeah for men this ain't gay
so dude do you know what dude lives are
yeah
i can't believe that's a thing it's just
i saw that it's like dude
just like
i think it's like flushable wipes but
like yeah
for dudes it's like it's like it's just
for it's so funny because y'all are
y'all's asses like they're so out of
control it's like you kind of have to
like tell them
[Music]
like
you're like
oh look it's cool like wiping your ass
is like it's what dudes do like it's
like and like yeah they're just like oh
sick
i think it's not
stupid dude can i tell you that that guy
who i was just staying at his house like
i think they're saying it's like dudes
like rough as it like they're like
durable but still flushable
i don't know they're like also [ __ ]
huge they're not like small baby wipes
they're like for
what is it for why you're wiping your
[ __ ] when you're done
i know but like uh if you don't need
like a bigger but you can also use it
but they're dirty they're stirred
they're stir dude
no
it's marketed as a flushable wipe but
they're like sturdy so like you could
wipe your armpits or like if you had to
like take it camping you'd be like tell
the audience look i'm right in the eye
and
no for sure but the guy whose house i
was staying at his toilet was surrounded
by like three containers of wipes that
were all open with wipes coming out
yeah
hilarious so he uses butt wipes
constantly
and um
when we had sex like
pace to use
i think it's a hygienic way
he was a clean person but when we had
sex like the whole room started smelling
like butt
severely
and i even think he's over wiping and
destroying the natural fauna in his ass
i think what it is is his ass is hairy
and so that's why he feels a need to
have so many wipes going on
and he didn't have enough going on right
before
we hooked up oh i hate it when that
happens yeah
so like if you don't use dude wipes the
room is going to smell like butt
yeah or maybe you're right
it
no it was significant thinking about
your doctors bill
and butt doesn't smell like [ __ ] it
smells specifically like i thought you
said he does use dude wipes
yeah there was three whole containers
that were all like so wiped out
but it didn't work
[Music]
[Music]
he's making fun of people with butt
cancer now
i hate it when people say roast me to
them and you can't actually say all the
things that you actually would be saying
yeah i hate it too oh
it's a pet peeve you're like could you
roast me and you're like no
anything that i would say would make you
stop helping me
he was mistaken he died
like the like girlfriend of the manager
of the sunset comedy club she was like
really begging me to roast her and it's
like what am i supposed to say like your
nose is kind of ugly like what am i
supposed to say
you know
so i was like no i can't i can't
i can't think of it like oh you're like
you look like a certain character or
something
yeah i don't know you don't say like
you're kind of ugly yeah no don't be
like me
yeah like
it's weird to like
to roast someone like one-on-one like in
conversation i feel like that never
works yeah because like you need an
audience
like to laugh at your jokes like yeah
otherwise it's just me you're just like
yeah
and they're like yeah
well you're [ __ ] barbie i was at
bianca's the other night like uh
i was wearing this robe and they look
there's like a group of like five people
roasting me for like 30 minutes straight
and that was fun
yeah
did you get bullied yesterday
yeah
it's been like 20 minutes yeah just
yeah really like can i
would you roll five [ __ ]
yes let's go
nothing ever works out for me
there's a song
playing the right instrument
[Music]
that's not true actually
does anyone want to give me a break for
an or
[Music]
okay here's an oreo
chris you should say like you know like
women these days they don't want to ring
they want a ring
dan that's so sick but why why don't you
why don't you use them it was more like
for women
well it's like i don't know
i feel like it's more my speed that's
like the things that you talk about i
feel like like society yeah and for you
that's too deep
no it's not
like
i wanted to give a girl a ring so i
but like for you you're always talking
about like yeah just like how people
think getting pissed off
i know
what the [ __ ] is going on was your round
five not getting pissed off
um
i haven't i've enrolled yet interesting
so
before
you still have a rule technically i
rolled it drop but i like it because i
got some resources in it resource drop
four
like fortnight
what's your favorite zoomer meme
zoomer meme yeah
a zoomer is a
person on zoom
so it might be a little hot
i forgot about
what yeah
it gets soft
i'm sure it's still good i'm sure look
this is good it doesn't look too soft
yeah it looks kind of okay it looks good
yeah it does
hot i don't want it to is more no
now you're thinking like the hans kim
and on skin five
you guys are destined for greatness dude
you lost the six members what would you
call what did you call yourselves before
the sixth one got covered
they told ourselves
the sexy huns came six
so
six dicks the hans cameron came in the
six dicks
six decks with more chicks
sticks no chicks did you like videos did
you do other events like besides them
six sticks don't you want to do it
that's a great one well
i mean
you're not coming to the stage six
sticks no chicks we practice it for a
year like
we might as well just do more
yeah we did it one more time but really
we got the video so that's all we really
need infomedia you live on and then the
group sort of fell apart we were like a
classic man damn
jerry god was the first one somebody
getting more jealous because they were
in the back more they wanted more face
time yeah the first time like that and
then the second time we did it the guy
played the music right when we they said
crayon five
and then we started walking up and
they're already playing with the video
in the background it kind of ruined it
oh that's what the [ __ ]
okay google
oh
pizza's done
right let me sell a card for me
okay google stop
sorry okay google
sorry
okay google
does anybody need any trees i have
i have trees zooming i need any trees no
no for anything i need some sheep i need
some sheep
sheep or brick
well then
would you roll a four
hey six dicks
okay wait christy are you sick
who's eating ramen
it's kind of a wild thing to be doing i
don't know i'm good
i have a piece of pizza
dude
reaching into the oven is the only time
like
we like have to wear them in yeah
you don't ever have to wear a bin i mean
you don't have to but you know
everybody learns everybody in the
pokemon everybody learned the same way
they touched it once
that again yeah i always do it but i
always just sit for a little bit
i always tried i learned through a
research paper actually i don't know at
the age of uh four
research papers at four yeah yeah they
started this they're starting out you
know we were younger i remember i didn't
know i was your favorite talent okay
like middle school poor favor
i guess uh we're not all born great
apparently weren't helpful
[Music]
just like that's how you find out things
as a kid yeah
well that's how smart kids find out
stuff they ask yeah and so they never
have to do anything they just they just
ask and then they learn
and that's why nerds like don't really
do anything
yeah
uh
asking
other than like
experiencing i don't know
yeah i got big noodle for you
thank you
did you get it from everybody or
what
you want one do you want some yeah
there's not enough left to split i got a
lot here i didn't really want all this
you want chopsticks
uh
i'll eat like one
[Music]
i do like chopsticks so but i feel like
the harmony you
you don't want any i'm good
you want which one
wait actually i want the other one
i'll chop this
it's like a bowl of
of
nevermind
yeah
that's positive
is it too soft
it's a little soft that's right
uh sorry it's soft i'm not even
so sorry tastes good though
well at least i dangled it in the air
it could have been a little bit softer
thanks that's what he said
[Music]
he's bringing me back to osaka
osaka 99
uh
three
okay
i'm
two winning four where you're tied yeah
dude they hate me
what else is there
who wants wood
who has brick
i need brick
wants sheep
who wants rock
we know you named everything
i need brick
i need brick
i need wood
who wants rock
or sheep i've got wood
uh when you want sheep
it's like a sheet sheet for
you just wood me earlier oh yeah i
remember what it was
yeah it selfless you a lot
yeah you especially you're like you're
most feisty when you're high which is
like so opposite from anybody
else people get like peaceful when
they're hot
yeah i get peaceful until
you're peaceful when you're someone is
very selfish
that's not true
you don't think you're a little more
selfish than average
i think i'm less selfish than you
but don't you think there's specific
ways that you are selfish that
go unnoticed because you're very
confident
no
who wants a
everyone has wood yeah
yeah
they're brick
are you good at cooking them yeah a lot
of them i think this after this the
pizza would be plenty for me
no he said that
i think that these are perfectly extra
i never said anything about these
yeah they're perfectly textured
to each of them you know i thought they
were pretty good thank you
did you wrestle in high school uh middle
school not high school
i when they so when i got to high school
i was like i did the summer before
freshman year and then uh
these [ __ ]
so i found out this there's this thing
called like
someone said you get ready to get your
oil checked and i was like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about it's like when
they try to stick their thumb in your
butt so you like wiggle and move so
there's like a it's common in wrestling
and i was like no i'm not into this
anymore
you can go
especially in college yeah it's like
dude it's like like if you're if
someone's pitching units
in wrestling it is
they were so like
their thumb it's like if you're on top
of them like about to pin them and they
they'll like try to is that legal though
it's a thing you can google it
so yeah
it's not polite
yeah
uh
i guess it's illegal i don't know if a
miner assaults another miner well like
in the football pig pile
yeah when they're all in the the
pickpock people are sticking their
fingers up holes and eyes
like they try to hurt it's like
it's a thing though i mean google it you
know you don't have to believe me
oh i will
so um
but like when the ref say anything i
think if the ref sees it they can like
say something but like he's
[Music]
i'm gonna do okay
couple roads
i think
what if you're on a first date and you
guys had to suck up neighbors the whole
time
lately you're like staring at each other
like
lately these videos of like
little tiny asian women like eating like
big
noodles have been like popping on my
instagram
yeah i don't know why
you know what comes up at night is all
those european gymnasts
and they're like wearing like bathing
suits to jump around
yeah
it makes sense
i have a sheep if someone has a hay
someone
need a sheep i've dropped in the middle
hans you know what you got over there i
don't want to try it
all right well i'm done
you should get
when can you play a development card
only on your turn right
yeah i think so
usually only usually only play one
developmental card per turn
thank you
man
the ramen bowls double as pizza plates
you want me to put a pizza
in a bowl
yeah who needs a triple threat box dude
from 2009
i don't remember the other thing that's
in there is it a dessert or is it like
garlic bread or something
there's garlic bread and dessert
whoa oh yeah and it pays for your
college
that's pretty dope very nice of them
this channel
mine
does anyone have a brick
i have so many good resources
if you have a brick
uh y'all have a break
what about
two hay for one brick
thank you
you exploit
all the time
well it doesn't happen that's why you
want it you guys think i'm too
i think quiet not quiet enough
for hans the perfect person that's
extremely good
i mean you don't talk loudly
hawks would you have that water when you
go second
please
do you sir it's good to be quiet or do
you think you should be loud and
boisterous
i think it's going to be quiet
entertaining is best for me
okay i'm done
why don't you entertain us christy like
my whole family and stuff it's it's
quiet it's kind of like awkward
sometimes it's hard and then my little
sister's boyfriend comes over and he's
like just on like he's just talking and
asking questions and answering questions
and i was like wow he talks a lot
and she goes yeah it's better
it's not awkward
like and i was like
it's not as sustainable
if you go through a famine or the
holocaust
you guys need to sit down quietly like
you guys should close the nine guys
we go through the holocaust
keep it down
what what is a number a nine
a nine
niner
speaking of the holocaust
yeah holla wheel of fortune do you use
that joke
i feel like that's something that you
would say
man the holocaust
more like how it cost a fortune
let's think of jack timmy's joke
i've been writing more like him
yeah
oh in tiny little letters extremely oh
really
because he's small
oh
he's a joke he's like tupperware more
like tupper where's the [ __ ] lick of
this thing
hell you smell like ellie oops i miss i
suck at basketball
those are actually good
i guess he doesn't do those with the
mics
huh
oh sean patton was there yeah
he just had fun
yeah that's nice enough to do the show
that would have been cool
it was really funny
did you kill it yeah
oh
someone was asleep though
was he pointing it out
the
girl after
the girl after him was asleep i have uh
some rocks
in the audience
i have a rock if someone has break
christ
i'll take that longest road card though
so depressing dude why don't you just
talk for no reason and just ask
questions
just make noise
like that
that's good to have in the time of
crisis hey why are we stuck in this
closet
here you guys have any matches it's kind
of cold
yeah
i like game of thrones except for the
last couple seasons
like game of thrones
i've heard that
game of thrones
he's pretty damn grooved
he's a grown-ass man
nobody's never heard that before
isn't he the tick tock
yeah
he's more of a flip-flopper
that's what tick tock is
did i already grab this no okay
five
um
i'm gonna play this
development card uh i'll take
everybody's
ore
yeah
white people do take everyone's ore by
playing a development card
they develop breasts
developed early
they develop mines in africa
and hands good for us
um
this mine is mine
are these oars yours
is that similar
yeah this mine is mine
this is
[Music]
those oars are your oars
because you get ore in a mine
what
why did you just point at me whose turn
is it it's mine's still still building
i think i need um
building confidence
he's working on him
does anyone want to trade for some
hay
i have sheep
nine
oh my god that robber is really [ __ ]
me
hello
this is blue
hello my
future family
do you guys um
you're gonna steal my audience
do you guys what's your biggest mistake
in life
can i find christy back in here
cause i keep winning
we lost
your turn
i shoplifted when i was in college
i got caught
i went to jail
it was a misdemeanor
yeah
you [ __ ] the miner
this mine is my lamp
chris hanson gave you external talking
to
yeah
like chris hands on
and
i heard he's like an actual dick
he got a recipe he's kind of a party
pooper if you think about it
that's his job
you're not gonna be having the time of
your life tonight
condiments and books you know that thing
that you love the most in life yeah
you're not gonna be doing that you're
actually going to jail
when you're trying to [ __ ] kids
dude i mean it is
like that must be tough like the thing
the thing that you love
is like
nobody wants you to do it yeah i mean
everybody i'm climbing but
if it became illegal to do
then i have to seriously think about
whether i wanted to continue
everyone was like no
yeah everyone's like ew you mountain
climb you should be in jail
but honestly i mean i got three
i mean like i love
the smell of gasoline but
you're checking i'm not gonna love the
smell of gasoline yeah but i'm not gonna
like huff gasoline because that's bad
and it's not sad that i have to avoid
that
but do you love it so much that like you
like you love it as much as pedophiles
love [ __ ] children yeah like i love
the smell of paint thinner and like i
never knew this about you i've never
seen you thank you for sharing
it's something that a lot of human
beings
but you don't love it like this
you're like willing to go to jail over
it
well that's what i'm saying is that like
i'm not going to first of all you're not
going to go to jail
like i'm not going to like
put myself in positions where i can
eat dinner because it's just bad
i'm not going to do that what about wood
it's not good for you i need a brick it
has a brick but like so somebody
[Music]
and they they're just drug addicts they
don't have like control over themselves
and pedophiles don't have control over
themselves
yeah like
just paint thinner just do anything else
just eat oreos do anything else
but they have to like
they usually raped themselves when they
were young so now that's the only way
they can feel anything anymore raped
themselves yeah they raped they were
raped themselves by other people oh yeah
that's how you get into that kind of
[ __ ] it's like indoctrination
you have to join the club
it's a real boys club i don't have wood
yeah maybe they they know that they kind
of liked it
well they just want that's the only way
they know how to show love i need you
they're like this is what love is now
this is how i get a lot of positive
emotions
i mean
uh i feel like it's not that bad like if
you like [ __ ] like a 17 year old or
anything
yeah but uh
or if you like are involved that's
because you're 23. there's i know this
guy who's like in love with like a 16
year old
and uh
he was just like he couldn't control
himself because he was like
he was just like involved there
yeah how old was he like you didn't just
want to [ __ ] her like he actually wanted
to like marry her
yeah i mean when i was 16 i dated people
that were like 23 and stuff
and they were really normal
how normal were they
super normal but
well i think that uh so they went for it
it's like a national forest
in that
i mean you just can't touch the children
it's like illegal
you get that what do i do
figure it out
not everyone has okay i'll do it okay
riley has
five points
santa's on two three four five
six seven points
are you building more yeah i wrote
i got a lot of resources after i i gotta
get rid of this wait show me three four
five
white
five two
nick
is doing terrible
damn
[Music]
he's like let's talk about six year olds
asia consent should be 34 years old
34 yeah i agree i mean girl is dead
some people are dead
this sucks smiles
12 that's 10. is it oh
yeah
my bad if you die when you're a baby
like it doesn't really count jimi
hendrix and janice joplin would have
never been able to have sex then if
that's the case
the asian consent they died at 27.
amy winehouse too
bummer
britney spears in her good days
it's pretty [ __ ]
everyone would be so ugly having sex
she's a slave dude anybody else used to
jerk off that dirty christina aguilera
video
30 something i'm older than you guys oh
you're my i'm 32.
all right you're around
how old are you 34.
uh 32. oh you're 34.
does anyone want to trade brick
sorry for just saying i think that oh
you almost being dead
i mean
rick 20 year olds want to [ __ ] or they
should they have like the best bodies
for it
you have brick
no no
do you think you get better at sex would
you roll
i didn't i didn't know that oh uh do you
think you'd get better at sex
yeah for sure so you're having better
sex yeah now than before
i guess sometimes i'm well i'll get i'm
out of shape right now somebody what is
it 11
stamina
yeah so they must be having awful sex
so
am i trading this four trees for a break
do you guys remember the wiggles
yeah
i think after their shows they just did
like a bunch of blow and like hookers
i want to know the backstage like story
of them
dude they're probably pieces of [ __ ]
yeah like
or they yeah i don't know
or they were christian or something
well like you're not it like you got you
have to have some dark side like for
every like thing like that
like there has to be like a dark
thing about you
maybe we can wikipedia with the wiggles
i would actually do it for hey for do it
isn't it just because our society is so
corrupt that if you're trying to be pure
and innocent then it just makes you evil
because it corrupts you with money
if we could just tap into our emotion
so you think we're just always evil yeah
but why why would that be the case i
don't think we're always evil i just
think it's like our natural
tendency like we have to have it we have
to have like some darkness i think you
can modulate it and
decrease the variability of how much
good and evil you need to balance
yourself out with
i don't know
i think that we'll always have it
because babies get angry and babies and
babies don't really they don't have to
like have jobs or anything
like they're they're taken care of and
stuff yeah but but they love what we
have in our society right now it doesn't
seem like
it's
just natural
i don't know i think it's possible
i don't think it's that hard
yo before they were the wiggles they
were called the cockroaches oh my gosh
[Music]
that's for grunge 90s babies
[ __ ] just a baby and a tank top
who wants wheat
who has rock i need rock
wheat i have sheep i would
um
dude you're i was looking at your
how you got cut off twice over
me
yeah
you can't go anywhere from over here
you're like
yeah but what do you have here you got
five dots right here i got five dots
right here
no i'm saying like if you want to build
roads you can't go anywhere oh yeah well
i already gave up along this road yeah
talk about don't give up dude never
switches
what's the other one what's the other
largest army or something
what's wood
pay
attention nine
let's go
you said how many
no one wants wood are we
i'll take some wheat but i have what do
you want though sheep i have some sheep
you give me two
wheat for two sheep
um
no sorry
one
uh one wee for one sheep here
i need a brick
or two i don't know yeah i don't think
so sorry
about the rule seven
seven
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
i mean do you guys think there's like
something wrong with me
no
they don't have any uh
scandals like
who's they
so what do you think about the wiglets
yeah
the whole situation i mean there's no
way like they definitely have something
something wrong
isn't it so obvious that they would do
it that they have to be on their best
behavior did you not move the robber oh
no
that changes everything there was a love
triangle
he's gonna shut off
his [ __ ] [ __ ]
you like when he when you pick from it
he's gonna have the resources no
nobody's drawn yet
he has
i just rolled yeah but you haven't drawn
yet yeah yes
what did you get no i didn't enjoy it
yeah you didn't i didn't get anything
you sexist i just dropped you're blue
what is it
machiavellian scheming machiavellian is
like cruel
basically
they definitely aren't into like some
cruel scheming it's like machine
learning sex stuff
it's like jennifer's body type [ __ ]
sacrifice a virgin
sacrifice
i would love to sacrifice version with
you tonight
all right
where's the [ __ ]
here you go right nina sanders
your orange
all right
so you roll now right there
did you pick up anything did you pick up
your wood
no wood yeah
two wood
uh does anybody want to get rid of
a
brick
for the six yeah
or a hay
you might want to get rid of something
you took the only card i needed that i
didn't need you to take everything one
of the wiggles married dorothy the
dinosaur
but their costumes had on like a tuxedo
and then she had like her actual
dinosaur off i had on like a wedding
dress
it's a sexy dinosaur
two
okay
two yeah
weave your head around it like all
tucked in the corner
two
nice i'll get a sheep
thanks for offering
before you sit down
wait i want to put another house down
but i ran out of little houses
yeah that means you ran out of houses
that's not fair
no you only get five houses
now you've got those cities
get a lot of development
cards
does anyone
want sheep or wood
you're
on the first bite
does anyone want
hey
yeah
or what no
never mind
do you want wood
sheep no i was gonna say i'll give you
sheep per head
brick
brick
no
i could give you some oh i don't have
any hair anymore all right
do you like dave morton
i don't know who that is
sex sex
do you like him
yeah
why
oh
because he's like funny and he also is
just like
he's like an entertainer but he also
just
is like a billionaire
because like he just owns a company but
also it's just like yeah and influence
he's like funny guy like
he's even more successful at first i
thought he was like
really
kind of conservative like too much
and everything like i thought that like
the show super duty yeah the shows were
too
broad and like they just put on like hot
girls just to be honest
yeah but uh
after that thing where he was like
helping businesses and stuff i like got
to know him more and i liked him more
get to know dave partnered helping
businesses
remember when he was helping like 50
businesses
[Music]
all right
that's it for me
he did an episode we reviewed all the
chicken sandwiches jesus popeyes
chick-fil-a just don't care
really
yes
i think papaya
no he rated it he had he did an episode
where he rated chicken sandwiches okay
like blind taste test of like the
just like popeyes and uh chick-fil-a and
like some other ones who wants wood
i have wood wait who wants
wood i would i need brick
or
yeah i need brick
i can give you a break if you can give
me an ore or a hay
i can give you a hay
anyone else
i need a hay
can you give me a brick nope
you like cause trades to be like
i don't have any brick he's a simple man
i'm a superman i just need it could be a
smoothie
hello darling
hello there's not much going on between
the ears
an impersonation of morgan freeman's
voice he says i was wow
okay
something like that
it was like impersonating morgan freeman
reading the book it was like
chapter one
blue was a good dog
when the summer rains came in yeah
okay no vaping in the house dude
good thing it's good thing it's an
apartment strict rules bro
seven
oh six
[ __ ] your sixes
dude how many cards do you have look at
that stack
me no riley
i want some hay riley let me hook me up
dude i got some [ __ ] yeah i got hey
yeah
put i got a sheep and you're waiting on
your turn though
wait joe turns
uh
yeah i mean i don't really like
the game's just gonna go out longer you
know
can you can you pass me the
can anyone pass me the lighter uh do you
have them correct wow
you have a far reacher you don't have
any bird now
i only have wood and sheet
i'll give you one hand for one
so yeah
i'm in there
your second guess it was too easy you
want me to negotiate it or what
yeah actually no
all right
sorry
that's all right
i'll be all right
anyone got brick or wood
i would
i have one
and i want ore
you
uh want hay
i'll take a hat
hello hello
who do you think is going to win
but you said you have break table has
turned against me it's
you need wheat for everything you need
to wait for settlements you need to be
for development
you wait for cities i've been only
trying to trade for the last three turns
what's it do for
let
five
six
did anyone respond to the group chat
seven let's go
uh
[ __ ]
what's saw
yeah right here is good
jesus i'll pick from
you let's go
all right dude oh douchebag yeah it's
what it helps me out over there
um
i don't it's still my turn i'm gonna do
do i not have any bricks
so uh what do you think about
the uh
you know
all the people that have been on kill
tony
i think they uh
i think that's awesome because we have
that and now like everyone knows our
scene everyone knows
everyone knows
our scene is like
everyone knows phil
i think it's dope but
a lot of that opens up the comedy scene
for awesome a lot obviously yeah i mean
just in the last year it's
changed so much and it's it's still
changing a lot it's a lot like joe rogan
shit's about to open i don't think he's
gonna be the last one to open a comedy
club
that's gonna be like once he's once
these building leases get up
get you know
yeah they're gonna raise the rent or
they're gonna [ __ ]
so
let's get at least
i'm down dude you wanna get a content
house
rv content rv
so you're independently wealthy
no
i mean
do you work
uh
no not really
how long can you do that for like
another
like another four months if i wanted to
four months probably yeah so not that
much
yeah
what are you watching
he uh he used to do comedy in fresno and
he would like live with his parents and
like
make a lot of money
no i i mean i live
i have my own house out there yeah i was
living
with my parents so do you rent it out
all right now yeah so don't you have
that mailbox money yeah yeah i'm gonna
go i got income from that coming in
mailbox money yeah
just go to the mailbox
oh sorry
is that a david lucas phrase a rich dad
poor dad thing oh [ __ ]
yeah i didn't read it i didn't expect an
ecuadorian to know it my turn
seven
yeah i was gonna say a lot of the people
who um
drive far to
do mics and stuff like that and shows
like
they still
don't even try really that hard like on
stage
like they'll like get off stage early
even though they drove four hours total
i don't know
yeah
it's like the artist
yeah
what don't say yeah i'm not into get
trying to get off early trying to make
sure do all my time
yeah
but i got a seven so i'm gonna take a
card from you
you gotta move the robber first they're
both the same oh no
what is that this
it's beautiful
so you might not take a card from it you
kind of know where you can move it well
i can pick from anybody it makes a good
head rest i guess
it's really comfy no you can only oh
would you play a card
no
if you roll to seven then you can only
pick from whoever is touching yeah
so like it would be white or red
or whatever or blue phones i don't care
what you do you could do blue put on me
all the whole
orange or red you could steal something
from one of them so she's an orange so
you already know i don't know
riley
don't do it to me bro seriously man i'm
not even doing well in life
i'm going to
build a settlement
yeah i keep getting sick
it makes me feel like i'm never gonna be
able to work hard because like i work
hard and then i get sick are you
supposed to rest when you're sick not go
out and
no gather i do like
i uh slept i sleep all day when i'm sick
and like i like yeah but it needs like
five days or sometimes more i don't
remember
i know how viruses work
this wasn't a virus
i'm glad everyone's sick here
yeah i'm not anymore i was sick a few
days ago but i stayed home and didn't go
out
i had omicron three weeks ago
i have crossed two days ago
you don't get omicron
twice seven times
i'm actually starting the counter
me and blue
the good dog
before i roll
let me play my hand
oh yeah
one two three four five six
wow
interest song
try this right
sam
relinquish
who wants wood
i need
i brick do anything
guys just pretend i'm not here
oh yeah let's start doing that three
[Applause]
did yeah if it's a night it is a night
whatever
hey hans what [ __ ] you
all right
why i'm not even winning
dude i'm losing it's fine
big time
uh
how many cards you got
got two uh three
i'll pick from you huh
she has one point
[Music]
what is it for
nine people nine
nine
basically people for golf so you just
kind of go and they have like food it's
mini golf no it's it's just like a
driving range like a big driving range
what's the difference between tough top
golf the same thing wait wait again it's
literally the same hey yeah not too hazy
looks nothing like a shirt
it's not so like call it a shack
jive shack
drive turkey
basically just like cvs and walgreens
it's like the same thing all right yeah
i tried these four sheep and then
i thought you said jive shack no
okay
yeah i mean sometimes i get bored at
topgolf because it's like how many times
can i just hit this ball for nowhere are
you good at it
yeah
i like it
but there's like games that you can play
yeah
and also it's just like a fun like
family outing
yeah
yeah it's definitely worth it to go
there
all right
jesus
okay
your turn
we got [ __ ]
when
you put a robber on the eight
oh me i got [ __ ] you said yeah oh so
we gonna
go
nice
how many catons have you played in one
day
guys
three biggest this is my one
yeah
is it too much hard yeah it's wrong why
don't you have a conversation then
because my brain cells stopped running
that's too bad you didn't even do dmt
whoa
touche
yeah
you'd be stupid for many reasons
yeah
should i do it fun to play with you did
you not do it yet
yeah you should do it
it takes like two minutes
four
seconds
sign
is that an anime thing
it's a dmt thing
that's like what the aliens the omega
signs yeah that's what the aliens should
be under frat
omega
doing all the rupees
one of my friends that claimed he was
raped by aliens
yes
i have a friend who claimed he was jesus
i have a friend who says that like yeah
the aliens would come to his house and
they'd be like running around they got
more and more like brave
where like they didn't mind him noticing
them like popping around and they would
gang-rate them
i didn't get to ask him that
but now he's like kind of gay just
because of all gangs
yeah as a child
but like multiple times what so maybe
he's just maybe his memory is made into
aliens because actually
yeah it could be anything sorry
no
don't you think that if aliens didn't
exist we'd still have the same number of
ufo sightings that we do now
if they didn't did not yeah
yeah
because people would make it up
anyone want rock
yeah for what
i only have wooden sheep man
so that's all right
i'll give you a round for two sheep
okay
are you sure about that
when do you guys feel the most beautiful
after a shower
a lot of water
get all that alabama stand off yeah oh
dude goddamn
what me
oh me
like i always do
six
nothing uh
what about you once
why when i'm cooking
that's not true
why is that not true
what is your why it's like a dance yeah
you're moving precisely it's not about
strength it's like
graceful that's when you feel the most
alive
you know
beautiful
is anybody have hay or
rock that they'd want to trade
for sheep or wood
i feel the most beautiful when i'm
taking a [ __ ]
like it's coming out easier when you're
pushing it
two different faces
both
which one though
uh
i just heard that in an interview today
this woman
she's on you
she did an interview in her underwear
oh that's funny it's like i feel a lot
and sometimes it's so bad but sometimes
it's
awesome she said i feel
i guess
but nobody who actually feels that much
would brag about feeling that much
because like yeah like if you actually
felt a lot like you would be like not
very into it
so what if you felt a lot but you wanted
to tell someone about it so you had to
strip to your underwear to do
where's the it rainbow guy
he's stripped to his underwear
what was that one video of that like
african tour guide guy
so i could find why are you gay no
hello
i want some
six i'll try one but
yeah
dude dumplings the word is literally
like dump wings i know that i have a
joke about that uh
wait who's the other guy's name mikey
biggs yeah mikey miles
and y'all are all just like
a hot dog no i already have hot dog oh
[ __ ] cause it's just like little word
observations yeah hot dog talk about a
hot dog
house
some of us
don't even make any more boys do you
think so
it's like you if you were better looking
oh wait we're on live
yeah and i mean that's not an insult
that's a compliment yeah
riley's
[ __ ]
um yeah it's an insult to me
well i think that it's funny because you
guys like just go through the dictionary
and you're like oh yeah let's write a
joke about i forgot i already have
africa
it's like
oh look
butterfly
sorry sorry sorry is it like it flies
and it's made out of butter
whatever dude like
works
yeah people like silly stuff
yeah
yeah they you know not everybody can
break each word down you know while
they're at their real jobs so they need
to go to a show and like
have someone break the words down
damn it's like uh
wait you should just bring a dictionary
on stage
just read through it
what's that uh anne's diary what's her
fan frank's diary he's like
anne frank's diary i mean she had the
worst thing happened to her and then
everybody read her diary
who wants what rock for what wait
yeah i don't have weight
i have sheep or lumber oh
no what about two lumber for one rock
sure three sheep
the deal has been dancing
huh
i win
you can use this when you're doing that
how do you win
i build a city with all these
that's eight points and then i have two
victory points [ __ ] you i had a victory
all right one two three five six seven
one two three four five so that's the
best i've ever done i usually
suck
all right we'll [ __ ] you
i think it's great because like that's
the future of comedy is like once we're
done figuring out like
everything we're just gonna be like just
having comedy for the sake of comedy
and like white people are further ahead
because
they've had more luxury time
they get to like go the furthest and
thought yeah in the future
soon we're all gonna be like riley
[Applause]
dude what's the point man that should be
a song
i'm sure it's so
what in lolita
do you wish you were a big black guy
no
what no
what did you expect she's like how dare
you yeah
what is the premise that everyone wants
to be a black guy
part of you wishes yeah i mean it would
be
much easier i think
why
yeah they had a great time they have a
great time
um
they also have [ __ ] shitty times they're
walk into a white girl bars and just
sling about that like i don't know like
whoa
so my soul isn't even allowed to try to
be a black guy it's [ __ ] hot
what a dumping in my mouth
that's
what what is it
yellow put a dump in your mouth that's
red it's kimchi the regular ones are not
kimchi colored what the [ __ ]
is it hot i don't think
[Music]
what are you doing oh with the fork
preposterous
here
all right round three
thank you
[ __ ] that
yeah i like i like that show
oh yeah man the dennis system
oh yeah dude
that shows crazy i dropped my monster
condom for my magnum dong
it's crazy what that show got away with
on fx first and then
the first episode is like
the gang
the gang gets racist yeah
that's a funny one
usually the pirate sucks on shows but
that was a good pilot
that was a good
yeah i'll take one more it would suck
being a pilot dude you're basically just
a bougie bus driver yeah like that's all
it is you're just like driving people
all day like i don't know why the job is
so glamorous my friend rodrigo has a
great joke he's like tip your pilot he's
a pilot he's like tip your problem you
tipped your uber driver to get to the
airport you don't tip your pilot i'm
really good on the uppy downy things
what's the upbeat thing no i'm not a
pilot
you have to be a pilot to get that joke
well it's like can't you imagine there's
a upbeat everything is the plane the
pitch
the plane is or the yaw
you always left him right i know
i know the intrinsic
i'm pretty cool
very hospitable dude what you